hello welcome back once again to the
corridor cast I'm really excited today
because we've got Sam at the table
we've got Nick and we've also got Wes
our buddy who's been in our studio
lately helping us with all kinds of good
things so everyone thanks for being here
yeah thanks thanks Jake yeah hey you're
welcome and you may have noticed that
all of us today are wearing classy ass
shirts that look amazing
we all look amazing yeah now these
shirts well they're brought to you by
today's sponsor now more on them later
but basically all you need to know is
that Mac Weldon provided them and if you
want to feel like you're naked well
looking like a million dollars well
guess what we've got the site for you so
thanks to them for sponsoring more on
that later yeah look for them in your
local man's wear section yeah if you
yeah if you're in a any department store
where do you keep your man's way bring
me to your man's where where man's man's
where and it'll take they'll take you
there so anyway that's gonna be great I
can't wait to wear this shirt the rest
of the day yeah all right let's jump
into it yeah yeah so we got some
interesting things that have happened to
last week's been an interesting week of
news and we wanted to start with a topic
today that's I don't know if it's near
and dear to our hearts but we maybe have
a little bit more from a proximity
perspective yeah and so the the Trump
administration it has moved to ban
flavored cigarettes and looks like well
I'll just give you the breakdown first
off who is the Trump administration I
keep hearing this real says the Trump
administration it's like it's the
executive branch of the Gulf da F da is
an egg's is part of the executive branch
I know it's a group of people who are
about to get fired or let go I know
we're talking about me to break this
down for you real quick I'll bring it
down real quick
at the time all right so here's how the
federal government works real quick as a
blanket statement for anything the
government does these days it's not a
blanket stay before anything the
government does it's the executive
branch of the federal government
basically the so just the way that
government works real quick is there's
three branches you've all heard this in
civics class the legislature which is
Congress in the house makes the laws and
then the executive branch enforces them
and the judicial branch makes sure that
they're in line with the rest of the law
so the executive branch is the only
branch of government where you have one
person at the top the president who can
say hey FDA you're under my branch of
government do this okay you're right the
FDA is part of the executive branch yes
so on and so forth I now fully
understand that's what they mean when
they say the Trump administration
because someone from the Trump
administration probably the the Health
General said hey it the attorneys are
bad Surgeon General Surgeon General and
FDA let's do something about it isn't it
cool how the Surgeon General General is
like a military dude yeah does he wear a
lab coat I'm just trying to he's got a
full I don't know but it's pretty
intense and it brings a lot of
legitimacy to the position yeah yeah I
mean obviously the military brings
legitimacy those things I don't
understand why they call him the Surgeon
General cuz it comes from like you're
the head of health he's the general of
surgery so for starters the Attorney
General is the head of the legal arm
okay the executive branch is the Surgeon
General is the head of the medical okay
because back in the day it's like oh
you're a surgeon yeah you know so the
same applies today all right so anyway
they ban they're gonna ban e-cigarettes
and it looks like it's gonna take the
FDA not not not all a flavored and it's
going to take the FDA about it's gonna
take about 30 days for this to hit the
market well why are they worth it so why
are they doing it that's why
there's been an outbreak recently okay
and in mysterious lung disease and it's
not that mysterious okay so so Nick
makes already coming in hot with this
his brother Nick your brother well
owns a juice company yes so I need juice
company let me let me just finish the
story quick let's let's just at least
set the stakes here
so supposedly well the US health
officials are calling this an epidemic
it has a mysterious lung disease that is
relating to related to vaping has
sickened hundreds of people and killed
at least six people oh so they said
that's that's what's being reported yeah
it's really scared to read something
like that
especially if you vape or you know right
smoke yeah I mean I I got a call from my
girlfriend she vapes she did smoke and
then I got her to start vaping yes
helped her in many ways but I'd rather
her not do it right of course right you
guys realize this is the death of vape
tricks gonna be a pro vapor you know
what am I gonna do this as this kid has
the lungs of a seventy year old from
vaping over a year that's that's what it
says for sure but the context I think is
what's really missing in most of these
like outrage let's give it some Connie
sure I would love some comments from
CNBC by the way it's not like some off
the branch yeah yeah
so I get the call from my girlfriend
she's kind of like you know I could tell
she was kind of upset she's like hey my
mom just sent me this article it's
serious these vapes are killing people
I'm gonna stop vaping like today I'm
like okay okay well that's great I
support that gave my brother a call just
to see cuz like you know he it might
seem like I'm bias
my brother has he started I think six
years ago an e juice company back when
like vape tricks were like you know the
thing yeah a vape tree height of the
vape culture like when we made a pecan
yes exactly it was like right around
there and like it's turned into
basically they have created a competitor
to like the the Joule which is like
guess the most mainstream yeah you know
nicotine vaporizer product they're
called baton sorry you can cut that if
you want but alright they basically have
been in the space so you know and his
job is to put out these media fires I
mean I think scrutiny is great when it
comes to to nicotine products I don't
recommend anyone do it and I think that
there should be certain regulations on
these things right now it's a widely
unregulated like market yeah like it's
it's literally the Wild West which is
good for small businesses it's really
bad you know for for the big
corporations and stuff so well you know
in a weird way though it it you know
like there is what anyone who starts a
company you make products that don't
kill people so that way they continue
buying your products is if you are known
for selling stuff that kills people you
don't get business yeah you know and I
think a lot of the industry
over the last few years like this has
been around since like 2010 2012 right
when they started when the artists vape
was forged we have yeah there's years of
remember when someone had one on his
hair not I knew I'm back in like 2010
they freak out and they were like oh
it's just water vapor huh so it was like
okay that's weird anyway sorry so
there's a big thing that I think is
worth pointing out with this they are
basically citing that there are hundreds
of potential cases of this and then at
least six deaths that are attributed to
quote-unquote
vaping now okay so the hundreds of cases
we have no idea what's going on but the
ones that where people have died most of
I think just just as a cursory glance
here these people are people with
pre-existing underlying health
conditions and are already like
suffering from complications with other
other things so this factor of a being
combined with these other health things
is cool code causing them to die so
there's there's also another crucial
fits are II um finish your thought so
I'm just saying like it's it's a little
bit unlike right now it's like we're
calling for a full-on ban on something
before actually understanding if
it's the source of the problem mm-hmm
you know and I think it's just al it's a
little head I mean I'm down to study it
I'm down to get the data I'm down to
make calls on it but once again we're
like they literally haven't even
released full data on what the heck is
even going on yeah which is like I mean
I I understand there's like a there's a
panic that happens whenever something
like this happens cuz like you don't
have the data you don't have even time
to do research on what the effects of
vaping are on people yeah but so I cult
so back to the like yeah I was like all
right calm down you know like I'm gonna
call my brother just cuz he's of course
been doing research on it like this is
you know yeah this is business and so I
call him and he says he points me to a
couple articles I believe there was one
I think it was the New York Times or The
Washington Post one of those we can find
it and link it but it basically pointed
out that these I think five deaths that
had happened all kind of in a similar
time span were all they there was one
thing they found the vapes they were
they were using that they think caused
these symptoms were all knockoff THC
vibes and nicotine yes they were THC
vapes made enough it like non-regulated
like here in California we have certain
regulations for these products these
were all made as black market products
and then sold on the street and they all
were cut yes and in meaningless like cut
like a like a cocaine dealer cuts his
cocaine with baby powder mm-hmm
these vapes they the juice was cut the
juice was literally cut by these people
trying to make more profit with vitamin
E oil yes this is the thing I was also
wanting to bring up all these people
suffering from these problem Mets are
also smoking these like ripoff THC ones
there's a really really well documented
case of a 21 year old kid who was vaping
and was hospitalized for two weeks they
found a thing called I think there was
called lipids Laden macrophages and
basically it's what happens when you're
smoking all this you're inhaling all
this oil and the the the issue is this
oil goes into your immune cells
basically so man does that like fat
cells are basically if you just imagine
like your big oily drops and you
immune cells so anyways I'd not an
expert on the science but the thing is
is that in that specific case there was
a THC vape involved with it and this is
not like the Joule stuff this is not
your 7-eleven stuff like this is your
janky off-market senior high quality
7-eleven over the counter babe this is
here dirty dirty cut Street vape but
once again it's like I'm not a proponent
of bathing I don't think people should
be addicted to nicotine I have done it
in the past I'm not a regular user of
this stuff so I'm not condoning it by
any means but what I really really
really hate is bogus BS science and
basically like reactionary laws to
headlines like this we yeah reactionary
laws are they can destroy nations yeah
they should not be its collective
punishment yeah reactionary laws are
kind of the worst thing ever
so I'm not in favor of reactionary laws
either but like there's there I think
there are a couple things that you can
say are true about this which is number
one there's been a huge increase in in
people under 18 yeah using definitely
vaping yeah so that's right away like I
don't think anyone's questioning that no
and then secondarily part of that is due
to the fact that these are flavored like
they're you know it's not everyone's
tried the tobacco flavor vape and guess
what it doesn't taste very good yeah you
know you should get the citrus bubblegum
one it tastes a lot better well sure I
mean but it's basically the first thing
you discover when you start vaping as a
person who used to vape yeah well it's
like it's also this you know the fact is
we live in a society now where 10 10
years ago if you wanted to you know
smoke some cigarettes at school or
whatever you know you'd have to bring
some actual cigarettes and find an
actual place to smoke them and now we've
smoking in the boys room
yeah now we've completely flipped it
where it's basically alright no you can
basically bring these tiny vaporizers
anywhere you can smoke in the bathroom
you can take a puff in the library and
blah blah so it's completely like
like basically it's open the door to
everything we're like taught and
fighting against you know for kids to
you know do would not do
now the vapes are in the library even
the Nerds to bring that back to the
smoking thing believe up until like the
early 90s at least in Minnesota if you
were a teen and you were in high school
that you could go outside and smoke
during passing time
probably yeah obviously they had a quad
that was for smoking yeah I think it was
like I think they like outlawed it like
two years late what I was I used to
write well I started doing nicotine
products when I was like 14 well when I
used to chew tobacco and then yeah then
you get older and you're like wow this
is not good for me do you actually
inhale the vape like into your lungs
I've never vape before it just sits in
your mouth yeah you inhale it okay
inhale it and it's also I mean these
vapes compared cigarette or even like
the mod vapes they're like it's way more
concentrated nicotine which is another
thing that people have me yes because I
don't use it a lot so like if I use like
my girlfriend's vape like just cuz
because the flavor is so dang good it's
like waffle flavored like syrup it
smells like you just walked into a diner
yeah and like they got a fresh that
Waffle House Blend
that's so funny dude like random people
will comment on it she'll be sure like
puffs and then like someone be like but
so it's way more constant the other the
other thing that's not good about them
is in addition to the fact that they're
flavored and kids can have way more
access to them than they've ever had is
is also the fact that the the actual
juice wes is on a gradient from like two
milligrams to like thirty and so if you
get the really strong stuff like the
twenty basically anything that's like
over eight is way stronger than a
cigarette cigarette is like what five
milligrams and nicotine or six and so
the thing is is you do
smoked them less often throughout the
day if you're a smoker and then you
switch to vape and it's like oh this
thing's ten milligrams and I could smoke
it whenever I want more often yeah
you're doing it catching us but you're
not there are benefits in the sense that
you can use them to wane yourself off
cigarettes that eventually that's what I
did with it yeah but for there was a
minute there where it was like I was way
more addicted to that than I was to
cigarettes and then I realized that and
I like force myself to stop completely
yeah but it was definitely I experienced
that personally and I understand like
and that was when I was in my like mid
to late 20s you know not and that's not
when I was 16 years old yeah I'm
thinking that you're gonna live forever
yeah you know and you could do whatever
you want yeah oh she's what every
16-year old things yeah someone said we
were talking about it and someone was
like they're like man that's really
scary
I I almost would rather smoke cigarettes
because I know what chemicals are in
there and then smoke vape and that was
just like yeah well at least I know
there's rat poison there's a hole you
can look it up I mean you've seen it if
you went to high school health classes
yeah that's like there's so many
chemicals and no matter what I would
rather smoke vape if I had to have a
nicotine addiction than a cigarette
yeah I don't think there's any doubt
that there's more chemicals in
definitely healthier yeah I would say
they're definitely more addictive as
well because they're easier yeah and the
Fed so that's the thing that's are they
are they as dangerous if it's if it's
more addictive there's easier access to
it
you could either nicotine that you
intake is higher so does that compensate
for the fact that yeah you you you know
cigarettes art you might use them less
but that's all I know and I don't think
I think you're right the data is not out
there yet but like I think we can all
agree these products are bad for people
yeah yeah at the end of the day and you
can choose to use them that's your
personal choice and we shouldn't
prohibit people that are of age yeah to
be able to do that but like you know
once again it's a collective punishment
things though yes
it's why don't want to make a law that
the collective punished yeah it's like a
9% of law abiding users are punished
and in this case 0.00001% are
potentially sufferings critical yeah
yeah effects you know so who knows
what's your brother's plan of action now
I mean like this this isn't going to be
a major hit to his his business yeah it
would basically it would mean that they
either dissolve the business I believe I
mean I haven't talked to him
specifically regarding that but they
dissolved the business or they switch
over to I guess what regulated just
tobacco flavor finalizing its guidance
true of all non tobacco flavors
including mint and methanol you see that
arm a creams tobacco lobbyists to me
let's just make the only flavor that
vape vape users are allowed to vape
tobacco flavor at the flavor of our
products oh yeah that seems a bit better
I mean the thing is honestly I feel like
you could make a neat like using this
kind of stuff they're going against
flavored vape products for I think you
could make like a pretty like the same
argument to ban fortnight with you know
what I mean like if you just remix them
a little bit and basically say the same
thing this is why don't you ban I
expected this I'm not gonna lie I think
it's great that you much rather just we
federally raised the smoking age to 19
and call it a day yeah I mean it's 21 in
California that should be the case
across the board smoking especially at
early ages it's extremely addictive the
first cigarette I had I was twelve years
old
well I know I just want to do it I
thought we thought it was cool from your
dad or whatever and we'd sneak out into
the woods and we'd smoke him and
basically you get high because they're
so strong and you're so young yeah and
that that didn't that it creates this
but again we were the kids it's not like
we went and bought them from somebody
that was 18 though I used to buy them
when I was 18 for my friends in high
school but we would steal them from
older people and just so you're not
gonna prevent all of it ever like your
first puff of a cigarette was
had it been gross yeah it was just
coughed I hacked you don't know how to
smoke yes you just inhale this huge
width of like really intense chemical
smoke and then you cough it all up and
then and then basically 30 seconds later
you're like that is that the is that
what you're chasing after that that
feeling yeah that's that's what every
that's what that's what nicotine
addiction is it's like there's that tiny
dopamine feed in your brain that and you
never I don't think you're ever quite
over it because there's still times I
mean I haven't the last time I had a
cigarette was when we were in the desert
like in May and and I still and I before
that it was like I don't even remember
it was a couple you know like a month or
two I maybe had like ten this whole year
and I still get that craving sometimes
and and all I do is say okay this will
pass I know it'll pass
yeah just wait like even right now just
talking about it I want I want a
cigarette
yeah you don't lose it yeah but any time
I watch anything with like a like it
said in like World War one or World War
two where everyone's just like chillin
and smoke so some way I want to be like
the boys yeah that's why Bollywood is
all over that cigarette lighting trick
shot cigarette like this kid right here
is kind of like the I guess the catalyst
of the whole situation the one that said
yeah I guess he's like 18 and he says he
doesn't know if his lunch will ever be
back to a hundred percent but he seemed
to have done like nicotine and THC
product so it's a mixture of both yeah
and then I think that's this like like
yeah you guys were saying earlier that
this articles failing to realize that
the death cases could have been more
likely caused by this cut blackmarket th
receive a pH is a totally separate thing
could have been I mean no yeah so I
think there's a couple things we
shouldn't be making reactionary laws
obviously too soon but also we should we
should wait and do still do a little bit
more health research and then also you
know I think we can all agree that this
isn't great
for anyone you know to do these products
yeah but it's your choice
we can't yeah waiting people that's the
thing like I think putting maybe the
money that they're gonna put into all
this legislation into educating
teenagers more about yeah what it
actually does to you and how those
chemicals can affect your brain kids I
mean like you could lay out all the
rules you want you said your start
smoking at 12:00 and nobody can tell you
anything different yeah yeah as a matter
comedy again like rap PSAs you make
about vaping they're still gonna be I
think actually they make all the flavors
[Laughter]
that you need somebody that you look up
to to tell you that it's not cool yeah
you know cuz that's that's the that's
the only people like yeah I want to be
like those musicians man I want to be
like this person man you know that's how
I was anyway is that you self-identify
with all these like artists and figures
in pop culture that you think you want
to be like and then you become an adult
and you're like wait a minute
Jimi Hendrix was a great guitarist but
he was actually kind of a loser in the
sense of like the way that he performed
his life yeah and then you see like they
died he beat all his girlfriends he was
a fantastic guitarist and that's why you
look up to him but I really did time I
really took dare seriously yeah dude I
saw a cop smoking a cigarette and I was
like yo he's breaking the law
[Laughter]
yeah I feel that man I mean back to the
topic of our first cigarette like mine
was when I was visiting my family
overseas in Belgium my cousin she rolled
up she rolled up cuz you can buy those
little markers when you're like 14 I was
also my first beer we went to a vending
machine got a tallboy I was like 14 that
explains it all but but I felt so bad
after I hit that cigarette for the first
time after I caught my freakin I just I
just failed everyone I'm the guy I'm the
person in the Dare poster yeah yeah with
that guys I think we need to vaporize
ourselves on to the next topic which is
today's sponsor Mac Weldon all about him
right now and now it's time where I tell
you guys about today's awesome exclusive
sponsor Mac Weldon that's right and
before you go anywhere before you try to
skip ahead I just want you to know that
this shirt that I'm holding in my hand
has real silver in it that's right real
silver and well that is also just a
super classy way to live your life with
the clothes that you put on your body
it's also because silver has natural
anti microbials in it and it also helps
regulate your body temperature a little
bit better than just pure cotton also it
makes a more durable shirt it just makes
a better shirt overall now if you guys
don't know about Mac Weldon they are a
premium men's essentials brand and they
believe in a couple basic fundamentals
number one make sure that the designs of
your products are smart sleek and simple
number two make sure that you use
premium fabrics in all of your products
and number three make that shopping
experience easy and convenient for the
people that want your products it's
pretty simple and that's what I love
about this sponsor is that their entire
philosophy is like hey we're selling a
t-shirt okay
we're not we're not gonna put a bunch of
crazy designs on it and try to make it
all flashy no what we're gonna do is
we're gonna deliver a durable product
that's gonna make you feel great and
look great and it's gonna be reliable
every time you go and get it nothing is
worse than when you find that perfect
shirt or that perfect pair of pants or
that perfect pair of boxers and you
can't find another one just like it now
you might even go out buy the same thing
and but guess what the shirts don't feel
the same I've had this happen to me I
found that I found my favorite shirt and
then all of a sudden I went out and I
bought a bunch more of them because I
really liked this shirt guess what they
didn't fit the same they didn't look the
same they didn't feel the same all of
that is now solved with Mac Weldon
they're gonna give you that consistency
they're gonna give you that durability
and they're gonna give you that great
feel that you have when you put on your
favorite t-shirt so if you guys are
interested in getting 20% off your first
purchase go to Mac Weldon calm and just
use the promo code corridor cast and
that's exactly what you'll do and I
gotta say I've been wearing this shirt
all day man I look better than I
probably should so huge thanks to them
for sponsoring today's episode and let's
get back to the corridor cast Wow now
that you know that I hope you are
already on their site really nice Wow
where did we all go all right cool okay
well moving on in the news like I said
it's been an interesting week we've we
talked about this in the past we've
talked about uber we've talked about
lyft we've talked about the
quote-unquote gig economy well the
California Legislature this week passed
a bill that would require companies like
uber and lyft to treat contract workers
as employees which would obviously
reshape the gig economy and adds fuel to
a year's long debate over whether the
nature of work has become too insecure
so all that basically has to happen from
this point is governor Newsom has to
sign it into law and he's he said he's
going said he's going to basically next
week and then it's going to affect up to
1 million workers in California now this
this doesn't just apply to over and lyft
yes this is the first in the world I
think maybe I can't speak to that yeah
maybe it's not first but it's but
it's these I've heard of its in the
other side part of it in the US so this
is gonna affect obviously ride-hailing
it's gonna affect obviously food
delivery posts mates etc uber uber eats
but also things like janitorial service
nail salon workers possibly construction
workers probably possibly all kinds of
contract workers could could now all be
reclassified potentially as employees
depending on you know how the how the
classified as contractors yeah so the
difference is that just to speak real
quickly to that basically there's a
there's a couple different ways you can
look at this but generally the law looks
that as follows if if you're you're a
contract worker if you have your own
business you make your own hours and you
like generally do things that are
outside of the scope of the normal
course of business that you're
contracting with that's the general
general gist of it if you you're an
employee if you are exclusive to one
company you you don't make your own
hours you work within the normal course
of business for a company and you
basically work at there they say hey
we'd like you to work on this you work
on it you don't make the decision you're
like okay this is what I've been hired
to do and that's basically the gist of
it now there's a lot of gray area in
there and so my quick analysis of that
isn't necessarily like 100% yeah but at
the same time that's a good that's a
good basic understanding of it and so
these economies specifically yeah are
these are these there's a couple
questions that come to mind are these
employees so you're an uber driver are
you an employee also is the is the
nature of your work structured in such a
way that's like that is uber a tech
company or a transportation company
that's a huge question or are they both
I feel like they're both and then also
like is the nature of the industry such
that like this is a new and different
industry and you know this is this is a
difficult thing and I'm not surprised in
any way that California is taking this
step because obviously it's a very
liberal very progressive state and so
for them to look at this and say we're
just gonna make we're just gonna force
companies make all these people
employees I don't know if that's the
right call Oh honestly I do understand
like there's very good grounds for it
but like man it's it that's a huge call
this is a nasty be made by a bunch of
people that don't work in those
industries like honestly first off
before I say anything - and before we
get any further here if you work for
uber or lyft or anything or if you if
you if you ever use these apps to you
know bring passengers around leave a
comment with what you think about this
below because I would really like to get
more first-hand context for this with
that being said there's a lot of really
real this is once again another like
wacky ass law situation reactionary law
another reactionary law that's reacting
to two things I think it's reacting to
the reality that uber and lyft drivers
and people who are using these
ride-sharing apps meal delivery apps
anything which are these semi
decentralized labor apps is basically
what I see here it's a it's a reaction
to the to the reality of that which is
that after expenses and costs most
drivers are generally working for less
than California minimum wage a lot of
there was a study that was done last
year basically I was nine dollars and
seventy two cents an hour is what uber
drivers make after vehicles cause
because they're handling there's gas
they're handling their upkeep of the
vehicle depreciation lease or annual
payments and monthly payments
there are also handling insurance
cleaning fees blah blah blah blah and
there are exceptions where I think uber
will cover the cleaning peeve blah blah
if there's a unruly pass
but the main thing is is that these
costs are being built into it an uber
knows that uber and lyft know that
people are paying these costs and they
still of course AMS you're great
now you can think all right well this is
a reaction to basically them creating um
an unsustainable business model which is
true
uber lost 5 billion dollars last quarter
everyone knows that this is all this is
coming to an end somehow because this is
the the thing is is that the uber
drivers are not being paid with the the
money the passengers are giving them
they're being paid with the money the
investors in the company are giving them
that's where that because that it's an
unsustainable they're not making profits
right so there's a churn going on
there's a lot of stuff happening here
and so I think this is honestly a very
from an emotional standpoint a lot of
this I think is a big reaction to that
which is simply they aren't paying them
a bit like it's any anyone who gets like
what it I don't know what an uber
paycheck looks like but when you first
get it you probably owe great bunch of
money and you know you don't you know
the whole budgetary work doesn't go oh I
need to put it into a car oh I need to
put into this so I can understand why a
lot of drivers yeah aren't immediately
like soured by the amount of money
they're getting but when you look at it
on paper after the fact it's like no you
you should honestly probably work at
McDonald's and you'll be much better off
well and and more stable cuz like a lot
of these drivers I talked to I always
strike up a conversation when I'm in an
uber and like ask about their job
because I'm curious it's like if they
are full-time then they are very very
strategic about when they drive they're
always trying to get like the most you
know prime times with the what do they
call the surge prices yeah yeah but
that's like it's like almost like like
trading in the stock market you always
have to be vigilant of like what where's
there an event going on in the city that
I can like be like yeah well I get that
companies did yeah yeah thing but like
not a researcher in their part but all
that for not even $10 an hour like I can
see why maybe be pushing for more more
money yeah I'm sure I'm sure
yeah I don't know if it's necessarily
the drivers that are pushing for this
yeah I don't have much context so yeah
I don't seeing this and from seeing what
you were saying it seems like that would
be beneficial to them wouldn't it yeah
well so there's other options okay so
I've got two more points they need to
touch on that are I think really really
really important another point here is
you have a driver's perspective here
I don't know how once again in and not
to say this in a dismissive way but I
don't know how relevant this is to the
bigger picture let's say like whether
drivers support it or not because I
think ultimately what this really does
mean is that a bunch of uber drivers are
about to get cut you know what I mean
like there's they can they can barely
afford paying the current workforce out
there and this is going to cut that into
a fraction of it so if your driver who
does support it there's a pretty good
chance that you're not gonna be able to
get work through bur soon because
they're gonna basically limit who can
log into the app and make sure that when
you're when you are using uber you can't
use lyft you can't yeah you have
multiple apps open on the same time so
because you are being employed currently
you're on the clock right there's
nothing that contractors are allowed to
do contractors are allowed to do that
and that's another thing most of these
drivers I talked to do both like it's
like they have to yeah all right so I
have one more point but if you guys have
any thoughts right now
oh please I'd love to open the back up
because I don't want to ramble too long
well well if you like it your points
have been contextualizing this every
single step for me okay what's the
person who wrote this and introduced it
to the California Legislature just
basically is running it on the
presumption that this this wrist quote
here let's be clear there's nothing
innovative about under paying someone
for their labor that's now I want to
take that and just make a comment on
that real quick like this is voluntary
work by people that are seeking to
employ themselves in a way that's never
existed before mm-hmm now at no point
ever before could you be like hey I own
a car I'm gonna sign into this app I'm
gonna go out I'm gonna connect with
somebody that needs a ride and I'm gonna
make money now if you get paid 10 bucks
an hour to do that like that is
your choice now you might say hey
there's not a lot of work that I can get
otherwise maybe I don't have a GED or
high school diploma and this is what I'm
doing you might say that this industry
is creating a gig economy overall that's
in disrupting people's ability to find
more legitimate work that's maybe a true
employment with benefits and things like
that but at the same time this is this
is voluntary decisions being made by
people to go out and do this work and
it's a good stopgap for people that
maybe have just lost their job or it's a
good stopgap for people that are just
looking to pick up a few extra bucks and
now you're you're taking all of that and
you're saying you're taking a huge
blanket statement about this whole
industry and you're just saying now this
is an employee employee employee
employer relationship and it needs to be
classified as such and I just based on
purely on the presumption that these
drivers are getting screwed and that the
companies are running away to the bank
under the guise that their tech
companies and not transportation
companies yeah and and that seems like
it's very it seems very emotional it
doesn't seem like it's made with any
sort of like sense or or understanding
of what the actual companies and what
the actual drivers and what the actual
people that are involved in that on a
day to day basis actually think it seems
like it's just like well they're not
getting 15 bucks an hour so they're
obviously getting screwed let's yeah
change this now and let's change it in a
huge way that's gonna affect millions of
people I'm not mad at this the idea of
structure of course you know I'm not mad
at that but it definitely I agree it
seems like it's an emotional move based
on assumptions and people they don't
actually know yeah it's like effing it's
like trying to like fix your MacBook
with with with a rock you know it's like
saying look at these old laws that have
defined how our employee-employer
economy has worked for a hundred years
and then a Macbook comes along and like
they're banging their stones tools
together and a Macbook comes along and
they're like
don't know how to handle this thing and
they bash it because this concept of
contractors and w2 employees
and sole legal framework for how
businesses operated for decades just
it's like doesn't functionally fit into
this situation and other does not
approach this in much smarter ways
because honestly what they are doing by
passing this is they are it this sets
precedent to destroy the internet and
I'm like I'm not lying like yeah we're
making a YouTube video right now this is
going up on Apple podcast but it's also
going on YouTube yeah and right now we
are voluntarily putting videos as a
business onto YouTube to make Adsense
and add money from it okay so are we
employees of Google now because we're
part of Google's actual business that
their ad business yeah we are now
crucial members of their functioning ad
business all right and we are doing this
for hours a day full-time uninterrupted
exclusively alright so with that in mind
now suddenly Google owes us a w-2 at the
end of every year okay yeah based off of
this okay every single thing you see
here Instagram are people on Facebook
anyone making video from like ads on it
this is the ripple effect of this
decision here has the has the potential
to destroy a lot of things and I think
it's really stupid because of that so
unfortunately it's like you know it's
it's yeah it's a it's a it's a rock with
your high-tech object man it's like it's
yeah it's not a right tool to solve the
problem I don't think yeah and I think
that that's that's it that's just it Sam
is like this this industry specifically
and you can apply the same thing to what
we do for a living yeah these industries
have never existed before the
traditional frameworks of employment
don't don't necessarily apply to these
you know and the whole question of like
whether uber is a tech company or a
transportation company I think is is is
an irrelevant question it's uber yeah
and it's not like the first
transportation company that arose they
were like guys is this a wheel company
or a wagon company what
we do yeah I'll tell you what you just
think you can't actually say what to do
but okay oh no no I mean I was just
gonna say really dumb analogy to add to
that but I wanted um analogy do chickens
have skin or feathers right yeah so that
yeah one choose exactly choose exactly
yeah how do you we can't ask that's
cheap that's so cheap but that's the
point
they they're applying this framework to
something that doesn't need it it's like
the same thing when people started
making YouTube videos and in internet
videos they were like is that television
or is that movies yeah it's not it's
Internet yeah exactly well I mean so
here's the thing there are actual steps
you can do to solve this issue
uber has proposed some New York City's
already passed some of this stuff and
there's a couple in between that have
been discussed but not implemented all
right so first off New York City
basically I think it's 26 dollars an
hour minimum basically they're
guaranteeing for uber drivers they make
sure Ober has to pay at least this level
because that's the that's the level at
which you need the Union make a living
to actually like make any semblance of a
living it's not the best but once again
it prevents people from falling into
that like oh the extrao nning in the
actual vehicle expenses and not actually
making a living um Elmont el monte
california 15 miles east of us right now
best city passed a $30 an hour
uber minimum Wow so so once again these
these these measures not necessarily the
most nuanced but they're but they seem
like wildly nuanced when it comes to
this conversation where you all right
let's let's just address this company in
this gig industry concept a little more
specifically car companies need to at
least guarantee these minimum wages when
they are on the clock we're not
classifying them as one thing or another
but we're just making sure people are
having enough to cover their expenses
and still make a little bit money on the
side for their living it almost seems
sorry go ahead and finish so that's step
one
all right and I think California could
have done something like that and it
would have solved eased everyone's pains
the drivers would be better off lyft and
uber would still have be able to operate
in a normal way and this won't set a
nasty legal precedent
for all other semi decentralized labor
networks yeah no i 100% agree and this
this sort of blanket approach it like
the one function perhaps that the
California Legislature could have served
here was to say like okay maybe you guys
have a minimum right because the whole
thing of why people were attracted to
over and lyft in the first place is
because it was way cheaper than a taxi
and it was way easier the reason why I
was way cheaper than taxis because it
was subsidized they weren't actually
operating at the it was subsidized by
the capitalists who invested into it it
wasn't actually representing the actual
cost of that service which is what taxi
companies were doing and so people used
it because it was used technology and
all this and that and exactly exam said
maybe the best place is for the
government to step in here would be to
just say okay here's the minimum that
you guys have to charge everything else
you can be as is right now it's just
applying this blanket yeah law it's
gonna stifle the economies and then
there's already people already so it's
already so hard to find a real like good
job here in California yeah that like
you're just further in the population
increase and like now there's this
housing crisis it's like you're just
exacerbating the problem you're not
solving anything exactly and you're just
gonna drive all the companies who try to
do anything like this in the future to
other states and another really simple
solution though I think they could add
here which is a little is very nuanced
but completely possible all you need to
do for these rideshare apps is basically
tally up monthly hours bringing
passengers from point A to point B and
basically apply that to the monthly
premiums that they're paying for car
insurance as a percentage where over
will pay them that as well yeah it's
some sort of nuance like that and like
you but the thing is is that but that's
also like the truth you you you yes you
are technically the client is I guess
the passenger in these these business
transactions but uber as a liaison is
the guarantee basically the guarantor or
whatever that these service will be
provided to the client and that the
clients money will go to the the I guess
the driver basically so they do have a
responsibility to Guerra
a safe and successful trip and so that's
like the very very that's like the
smallest step they could do is basically
just pay for a portion of the car
insurance while used on the clock yeah I
mean I can't speak to whether or not
that I'm not an uber driver but like I
think that's not a bad idea and I think
that there's a failure here to actually
sit down with the people that are
involved and really get really yeah I
totally agree I think that's the
ultimate thing here it's like no one is
talking about this in a productive way
and this is basically classic California
lawmakers just just wrapping stuff up in
red tape without bringing it and kicking
it into the world like you're putting it
into the fan bucket taxi drivers they
yeah they have this underlying beef with
you know uber and lyft and I know just
in New York in general like in terms of
catching a ride they'd rather me ride
with them than catch up or lift so I
feel like this is something that's been
you know brewing for a minute so yeah
possibly you know the taxi driver
companies got together and were like yo
like do you think this was like taxi let
just like taxi lobby I feel like it is
taxi big taxi yeah I think yeah big taxi
should have probably that that's what
this is honestly heading towards though
either way it's like we are heading
towards a situation when the actual
price of uber and becomes back to equal
with the actual price of taking a cab
somewhere and it all kind of evens out
and like I think there will be a it'll
be net lower because I think the concept
of the uber app is a cost saver when it
comes to just the efficiency of picking
people up and delivering them and
finding work right but ultimately it's
it is about making sure that people are
getting a fair wage and the taxi
companies provided that to their drivers
and uber isn't doing that currently but
it has been it's been moving towards
that for like the last few years
Uber's prices have been going up because
of the fact that they're realizing hey
we're losing money we're not making a
profit
all these subsidized rides are starting
to kind of like the initial hypes over
there you know they're probably looking
to sell right now or be acquired by
another big
tech company so yeah you know I don't
know as a consumer I would be willing to
pay a couple cents more if it meant that
the drivers could remain free agents in
a way and also make more money I think
it's so convenient yeah I think the
reality is that we're not gonna have a
choice and you have to be welcoming all
right
if this gets signed into law we got a
significantly more and it'll make taxis
pretty competitive again well right well
yeah and that is a Wes you definitely
right the taxis failed to take advantage
of a market opportunity big time the the
big time and and uber and lyft took
advantage of that the same thing happens
in every industry when an industry gets
too old and calcified there's somebody
else that comes along and disrupts it
and that's great and we don't want to
have the old calcified industries
prohibiting the people from coming up
much like all the car companies have
done much like a bunch of other
industries have done oh yeah this
happened all throughout history right
and that's bad so you need to allow
these new people to come in and thrive
after but yeah that's an interesting
thing because when you sit to take it to
take this conversation in slightly new
direction to look at people like us who
make a living if making videos if Google
was to tell us hey you guys are
employees now and you now sorry we don't
want to do this but you now have to
decide who killed the entrepreneur hey
man Weldon or hey hey Jake you got to
take that shirt off why you're you're
competing with Google's ad now okay no
yeah that's the thing it's like now we
can't post videos on Facebook we can't
post videos we can't post the audio only
podcast on a bunch of other podcast
platforms it has to be on Google
podcasts and we can only post on YouTube
god forbid w2's god forbid they want the
IP to everything to you
yeah and that's the thing now is you now
that you work for us by the way
everything you make is ours and and and
you can only get paid from us you can't
take your own integrations everyone
would leave and they in like literally
creators would go and start their own
back to television like TV could lobby
for that
yeah but creators at this one I think
are powerful enough where we could go
and create our own networks yeah yeah I
mean the true lot the true loophole for
that is you just make an ad-free network
where it's just like no one there's no
exchange of money here basically such
thing as an ad-free we're gonna have to
were like yeah so that's idiocracy so
that would be good for for what we do
and it wouldn't be good for people that
watch it wouldn't be good for the
creator's and man yeah I don't I don't
think that this will happen but this
could potentially be sieved perceived as
precedent wait actually you know what no
big deal you know why because in a few
years I'll be robots driving those cars
anyway last topic guys Sam almost forgot
yesterday that it was 911 I almost
forgot and for the first time I was very
busy and tired yeah everyone's busy
everyone's
remember there's no sin for seven
there's no excuses not therefore not
eleven guys if anyone out there if
you're if you're listening right now and
you did not remember or you forgot that
is nine eleven um I just heard George
Washington turning so it was nine eleven
yesterday there we go that's all I'm
saying I know it now just to set the
table straight yeah that was 18 years
ago 18 years ago that's crazy yeah
that's crazy
everyone everyone that's over the age of
like 25 I feel bad for the people who
like weren't alive when that happened
well it just let's talk about Peter for
a second they could we because you
remember that version of America that
was super dope where gas was ninety
cents a gallon yeah dude I remember it
was 77 cents a gallon and remember how
you could just like roll in the airports
anywhere you wanted to go you just walk
up to the terminal and say hey someone
who got off the plane yeah that was good
times that's pretty crazy it was like it
was like a true utopia yeah well so
that's so like that's what I want to
talk about in have we where have we
improved as a nation and where have we
gotten worse because of 9/11 yeah I like
it since 9/11 it's a big give me
anything this is an open topic I think
everyone got way more cynical after 9/11
so I don't think that's an improvement
that's a bad thing
cynical how just in general I like I
mean I mean do you think we're even yet
they killed like 2,000 of us how many of
them did we kill oh we've definitely
killed way more what's the ratio where
work we can call it quits yeah and the
one well that's not really what about
though you know that's not really what
our involvement our involvement just to
tarp on that a second for a second Sam I
mean our involvement overseas at this
point I think is just to is to promote
and to sustain global stability yeah
because if you remove the United States
Armed Forces from the world
the world becomes a very unstable place
yeah it does and whether or not like we
as Americans want to believe that that's
true that's that's definitely true it's
actually yeah so weird men to think like
that that position of I guess power or
responsibility or I mean it depends who
you ask a lot of I mean most people from
other countries that say why the heck
are you guys doing that of course well
it's that all those countries are also
saying why the heck are you doing this
but then on the other hand they're
saying you have permission to put your
base in my country yeah it's the same
thing with the with the drug world yeah
like you like the only thing that keeps
really bad people from from taking each
other out is like somebody else that's
standing there between them you know and
and it's weird to think about the world
on those terms but the world is filled
up with human beings and that's how
human beings are ya know it's like the
simple thing of do you think more people
would like shoplift if there weren't
security cameras in Walmart honestly
what do you think yeah way more stuff
will get stolen right so that's why they
put them everywhere
yeah so that's true like that's that's I
feel like it I'm actually I feel like
the public perception of that has gotten
I mean really the public perception of
like American being bad guys overseas
really started with Vietnam right over
time no I feel like that that really
wounded the country I think in a lot of
ways but it's it's gotten better well
yeah I think I was like one more time
collectively like what our presence and
purpose overseas is a little bit more I
think but there's also some people that
are on well it's awful it's so complex
like we weren't the first ones to be of
I mean the British tore it up over there
and Europe you know the Russian belch oh
God don't even start on the Belgians do
Belgians DM effort yeah yeah the Congo
the Belgian Congo is like yeah talk
about genocide and like horrible things
yeah the British did it you know a
number on you know Pakistan
Afghanistan and all that well what we
called you know what those names are all
new yeah like what yeah under 50 years
old and the Russian are in Afghanistan
for a long time yeah the US was not the
first in that area now to uh to shake
things up and try to hold it down in
their definition of what is a country
you know yeah that's the other thing
about isn't cultural that it's easy for
us to look for people in a first world
nation state to look at the rest of the
world would be like that's a first
that's that should be a nation state the
whole concept of a nation state there's
just there's a whole different concept
of culture in a place like like
Afghanistan or Iraq or wherever that
isn't the same as here and I think it's
like we've gotten a little bit better at
at like understanding that I think as
people with with the aid of the internet
and with the aid of the Information Age
I think that actually is a benefit that
we've we've become better at sense now I
haven't I could I feel like I could
really touch on this just because my
whole life I grew up on a military my
entire life so where Okinawa Japan I
moved there in third grade and I stayed
there to my senior high school
and coming to America was a huge culture
shock so like my first you know like you
know being born in California then
moving to Virginia Caroline you speak
Japanese well enough to get around no
it's crazy you know like on a military
base you're very sheltered you're
surrounded by a gate there's military
people like well all the way around
American soil right it's American soil
but when you go on to the military base
you have to present your ID you present
your ID with everything you're shopping
in a grocery store or the shop at or the
commissary you have to present your ID
if you don't have your ID you can't get
groceries so when I came to the States
it just felt like a free-for-all out
here I was super intimidated I was like
wait I can't get my my medicine inside
the hospital like when when you're there
like no I I just felt safe all the time
I've you know you get sick you go to the
hospital downstairs your medicine is
there here you have to go to like CVS or
Walgreens in Japan going to the gym
there's no membership fee there's no
pain okay you just go and work out on
the base yeah on the base yeah so there
was there was so much there was so much
freedom but there was also so much
restriction you know like if I was
caught in schools you know smoking a
cigarette
that could potentially get my mom busted
down and rank really mean so like this
is read this is the reason why I was
always in line yeah you know like I
don't want to breaking the rules because
being a dependent could affect your
parents job period I've seen different
kids get their parents kicked out the
military for doing dumb [ __ ] oh okay
yeah it's it's it's just a different
world so like the military presence on
or if you if you messed up out in town
like you can get your parents busted on
a rank so you had to be on your P's and
Q's literally all the time so I don't I
don't think it's bad that we have the
military presence on these different
bases because one it you know it gives
you regimen as a kid and then when you
come out into the real world I'm because
I moved around so much I get along with
everyone there was it was a melting pot
of so many different cultures and you
know everyone is mixed with something
different so there would be a German and
Japanese girl that goes to my school or
a Native American and Filipino kid that
goes to my school and then when I come
to the states I'd run into someone that
I met on a military base someplace else
and it's like oh this is yeah like I'm
just curious like speaking to that how
like is the base on Okinawa like an
integral part of that Island there's no
eight basis there's an eight different
basis so I went to like there's two high
schools in Okinawa and like the whole
island of Okinawa is like two hours up
and down but there are different
military installations there so I went
to elementary school that on this place
called Kinser I went to middle school at
this place called Leicester middle
school and then I went to high school
there was it there's one Air Force Base
there but majority of them are Marine
Corps bases so I went
the Air Force High School in the Marine
Corps high school and when there's two
high schools that's arrival all the
functions of society just like boiled
down and like this island and then
furthermore into this base and then you
try to identify with what you see on TV
it's so weird like nobody we we everyone
would say they're from someplace like I
would say I'm from New York because
that's where my mom's from but I'm I'm
from Japan you know like this is where
my prime years were growing up so like
you did you get these kids that would
come from different parts of the states
and they'd be like oh yeah this is where
I'm from you know like and there'd be
like a weird-ass rival but it's not real
yeah we're stuck we're military kids
it's it's just a different religion so
like when 9/11 happened I moved to the
States and the base the culture of the
base the environment was just completely
different after that you know like where
you could go anyplace they were now guys
with ak-47s guarding this part of the
base so the base started being
partitioned in different ways really
yeah and you notice that I'm almost
immediately immediately immediately yeah
it was when you moved to the States
where'd you go I moved to North Carolina
moved on to Camp Lejeune and I remember
walking into class and seeing the TV and
I thought it was a movie and then from
that point on everything changed you
know like it was it was locked down I
think I think they started having like
curfew hours on the base I can't really
remember it's a little bit hazy but it
was it was crazy
so just to just to go back to this like
I guess international presence the basis
on Okinawa mm-hmm have been there
obviously since 1945 yeah is are those
necessary and as somebody who's lived on
them I mean I was in the military so I I
don't know you know like it's it seemed
cool but you know that I think they're
giving some of the bases back and some
of the land back - okay
though I feel like my middle school base
area they're given that back to the
Okinawans is there a large I mean
there's obviously still population
larger yeah no one popular okay huge
population so what's that like what's
the is there a clash of culture is it
kind of like different times sometimes I
had to go like I remember I went to I
would go to a store and like some people
you know they kids would steal but like
specifically being black you know based
off what they see on TV some of them
would just follow you around you know
like literally like follow you around
and make sure you weren't around the
store like straight up straight
observing what you're observing
everything I'm doing and you know is it
it'd be like older people but yeah it
was crazy you know just the stigma of
whatever they saw on TV and they think
like that's I'm like in fifth grade I'm
just it's interesting to think - and I
think this goes back to a little bit of
this like reactionary sort of
legislation and just that that
conversation but just to just to put
things into context here like 1945 was
what 74 years ago now that's the effects
of that time are still very present 74
years later and so I think it's
important to just keep in mind you know
as like we go through this stuff in like
18 years since 9/11 and when we make
these decisions collectively
with our legislatures and stuff like
think about this this these are
decisions that were in Okinawa 75 years
later still a ton of the lifestyle and
yeah the people that are there are
because of decisions that other people
made 75 years ago mm-hmm it's worth
thinking about yeah it's pretty insane I
mean that's that's that sets the stage
World War two and us basically getting
footholds in all these other places
Germany - I mean we still have a huge
military presence in Germany and your
other places in Europe yeah and it's
like that's when we really stepped on
this day
just like America's now they're gonna
clean up the mess you know of world war
two and then Korea it was like I was
like yeah commies like that was the
first like Cold War change was like kill
the commies yeah from there but but
honestly I mean the reason it is the way
it is is because I mean from hardcore
history everything I've got anyways like
three hardcore it you know end of World
War two you have the United States and
Russia's the technical victors I guess
if you'd say that
as far as like the largest fighting
forces and the two countries approached
the post war I guess reconstruction in
different ways and in different areas
where the United States ends it ends up
taking the larger presence in Western
Europe and Japan etc etc and Russia
basically I mean they're backed up
against the German German II is like the
the middle ground so to speak and so
literally Leland yeah and no this one I
mean like yeah physically and so it's
like you kind of have the United States
take that larger responsibility like
right off right off the bat there at the
end of the war and you know it seems
like that kind of has this like ripple
effect up until this day where yeah I
think ultimately they're just you just
start doing it and then suddenly
everyone turns to you because you're the
guy doing it you're like oh oh yeah I
realize I was oh you know it's like it's
a it's a difficult thing especially for
the u.s. right now because we're in that
position where we have to remain in that
position but at the same time the you
know each each individual community even
even go further down than a national
level each individual communities in a
way needs to be responsible for itself
mm-hmm
it does it does and so you have to
instill people's light and that comes
down to each individual so you need to
instill like this sense of individual
ownership of your own actions but then
also make sure that it's still a
balanced playing field yeah I think
we'll get there and I think I think a
big part of it is looking at how we use
social media and I think the the concept
of like war has dissolved quite a
except the only like you only except for
like superpowers basically you know
us-russia the concept of war between
those two nations that's a that's a
pretty traditional war I'd feel like as
far as like how it's gonna end up being
fought if it gets physical but we see
like in Afghanistan or like Iraq etc
like its traditional war is I feel like
kind of maybe I don't know well use what
they said the world were one but I mean
information and people connect with each
other and talk and why bring all your
guys out in the middle of a field and
shoot the enemy when you could hide in a
bush and press a button or you can get
out it's on Twitter bot yeah exactly I
said enough to fire yeah and if you have
to fire guns just have a robot precisely
yeah but I don't know like I forgot what
my point was you know that that social
media has I mean we'll see if people
would but you know I feel like a lot
like I'd go back and forth on it but
when you contextualize it with like the
post-world War two reconstruction and
what we look at today and all that stuff
you know I think a lot of the people for
who would be against like the US
military bases or like the concept of US
military presence it's a little bit of
like the the angsty teen discovering
themselves you know and like they're on
the verge of getting independence but
are currently still like I'm embarrassed
because my mom's always following me
around trying to make sure I'm safe you
know it's like kind of yeah that's the
situation that it became you know and
like for better or worse it's it's like
that probably will change I don't know
if we'll have our universal unitary
earth government anytime soon I mean
it's it's kind of scary because yeah you
know I mean I think it's gonna change
definitely I mean cuz like post-roll row
two is like the US was it I mean it
still is a joint effort the military is
you know our military they do exercises
every year with all that you know
Germany you know Scandinavian countries
mm-hmm but there's like a big resurgence
of kind of nationalism going on right
now so I'm interested to see where that
goes and like if the bases are gonna get
ousted because I feel like now these
countries are like it's kind of like
this like weird repeat
fact that you see with the immigrant
crisis so hmm we'll see where that goes
next time yeah next time next time I'll
talk another topic that's hardcore
podcast core podcast hardcore corridor
cast oh man alright guys well that was a
great podcast thank you everyone for
contributing guys for being here and
signing out peace